trump's lawyers lay out his impeachment
defense the media encouraged the biden
team to crack down on
misinformation and democrats aren't
looking to compromise on covert relief
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
show is sponsored by expressvpn protect
your data from big tech with the vpn i
trust visit expressvpn.com we get to all
the news
of the day first a reminder you are
spending way too much money on that cell
phone bill like a lot
too much money on that cell phone bill
go rectify that right now
by heading on over to puretalk usa over
a thousand of you my extremely wise
listeners have made the switch
from your overpriced wireless carrier to
pure talk over the past couple of months
what exactly is everybody else waiting
for out there if you're with a t verizon
t-mobile
your family could save over 800 a year
just by switching to pure talk
you get the same great coverage because
they use the exact same towers as one of
the big carriers you can even keep your
phone and your number but you will save
a fortune by the way puretalk is the
top-rated wireless company by consumer
affairs
with the absolute best customer service
team in the business based right here in
america
and it gets better because right now you
get unlimited talk unlimited text and
six gigs of data for just 30 bucks a
month if you go over on the data they're
not going to charge you for it which is
a pretty spectacular deal grab that
mobile
phone i'll pound 250 say ben shapiro do
you get started when you do
you say 50 off that first month now
pound 2 5 0
say ben shapiro pure talk usa is simply
smarter wireless save yourself
hundreds of dollars a year pure talk
usage pound two five zero say keyword
ben shapiro and save 50
off your first month and a lot more
going forward alrighty so
we begin with president trump's legal
team laying out his defense
for the senate conviction trial that is
going to take place over the impeachment
charge that was passed in the house with
all democrats and 10 republicans voting
in favor according to joe crull writing
for daily wire
former president donald trump through
his lawyers bruce castor and david shane
on monday responded to the article of
impeachment lodged against him by the us
house
of representatives here is their full
response
they say the 45th president of the
united states through his council hereby
responds the article of impeachment
lodged against him by the us house of
representatives by breaking down the
allegations
out into eight of vermins and
respectfully represents one
the constitution provides that the house
of representatives shall have the sole
power of impeachment
and the president shall be removed from
office on impeachment for and conviction
of treason bribery or other high crimes
and misdemeanors so answer one is
admitted in part denied in part it is
admitted
the constitutional provision at a vermin
one is accurately reproduced
it is denied that the quoted provision
currently applies to the 45th president
of the united states since he is no
longer president the constitutional
provision requires a person actually
hold office to be impeached
so this is the case that you're hearing
a lot of congressional republicans make
a lot of senate republicans are making
this case today
in that case is that the constitution is
designed to remove somebody from office
it is not designed to go after somebody
after they have left office well the
thing is
the senate conviction is different than
the house impeachment it would be very
weird if the house started to impeach
somebody after they had left office but
since the impeachment took place while
trump was in office and the senate
can convict after the person leaves
office that is the countervailing case
but this is the case
that trump's lawyers are going to make
second
the the impeachment charge suggests that
section 3 of the 14th amendment to the
constitution prohibits any person
who has engaged in insurrection or
rebellion against the united states from
holding any office
under the united states they say that
this is in fact what the constitution
says but
the president didn't engage in
insurrection or rebellion against the
united states the 45th president
believes and therefore a verse that as a
private citizen the senate has no
jurisdiction
over his ability to hold office and for
the senate to take action on this
development would constitute a bill of
attainder
in violation of the constitution in
other words you're now passing a law
after after the fact in order to go
after me
for a thing that i didn't do in the
first place okay third
the allegation in the impeachment
suggests in his conduct while president
of the united states
in violation of his constitutional oath
faithfully to execute the office of
president of the united states
and to the best of his ability preserve
protect defend the constitution in
violation of his constitutional duty
to take care that the laws be faithfully
executed they say no that doesn't apply
they say to the contrary at all times
trump fully and faithfully executed his
duties as president of the united states
and at times he acted to the best of his
ability at all times he acted to the
best of his ability to preserve protect
and defend
the constitution of the united states he
never engaged in any high crimes or
misdemeanors and since again he is no
longer president
none of this applies okay fourth they
look at the impeachment charge
and they say that the impeachment charge
with regard to his actual speech on
january 6th
is over broad according to that
impeachment charge in the months
preceding the joint session trump
repeatedly issued false statements
asserting that the presidential election
results were the product of widespread
fraud
and should not be accepted by the
american people or certified by state or
federal officials
and the impeachment charge also suggests
that on january 6 the senate met
in order to wreck in order to certify
the election and he interfered with this
here's what they say
they say it is admitted that on january
6 2021 a joint session of congress met
with the vice president the house and
the senate to count the votes of the
electoral college
it is admitted that after the november
election the 45th president exercised
his first amendment right under the
constitution
to express his belief that the election
results were suspect since with very few
exceptions
under the convenient guides of the covet
19 pandemic safeguards states
election laws and procedures were
changed by local politicians or judges
without the necessary approvals from
state legislatures
insufficient evidence exists upon which
a reasonable jurist could conclude
that the 45th president's statements
were accurate or not and he therefore
denies they were false okay now this is
going to be weak t
okay but here's where they actually have
a defense
even if it was false the president can
say false things presidents say false
things all the time barack obama was
quite fond of doing this
i know contrary to public opinion barack
obama the greatest lightbringer who ever
was never lied at all
except when he said that if you liked
your doctor you could keep your doctor
but it turns out that presidents all the
time say things that are factually
untrue
and here's where trump's lawyers have
some room to move they say like all
americans the 45th president is
protected by the first amendment
indeed he believes in there for a verse
that the united states is unique on
earth and that its governing documents
the constitution and bill of rights
specifically and intentionally protect
unpopular speech from government
retaliation
if the first amendment protected only
speech the government deemed popular and
current american culture it would no
longer
protect at all since the 45th president
is no longer president he can't be
removed anyway they keep coming back to
this point over and over and over okay
then they move on to the next part of
the impeachment charge that impeachment
charge
suggests shortly before the joint
session commenced president trump
addressed a crowd at the capitol ellipse
in washington d.c
there he reiterated false claims that we
won this election and we wanted
in a landslide trump's lawyers respond
they say it is admitted that trump
addressed the crowd at the capitol
ellipse on january 6th as is his right
under the first amendment to the
constitution
and expressed his opinion that the
election results were suspect as is
contained in the full recording of the
speech
to the extent that a vermin five alleges
his opinion is factually an error the
president denies this allegation okay
trump is going to continue saying that
the election was illegitimate he's never
going to stop saying
that the election was illegitimate the
question is is that in and of itself
impeachable
given again the last four years and and
by the way long before that i mean for
for
george w bush's entire presidency
members of the press members of the
democratic party suggested that he was
not a legitimate president because
of course he lost the popular vote to al
gore in 2000
it is not enough to impeach somebody
from public office because they believe
wrongly that they won an election that
they actually lost
okay furthermore the impeachment
allegations suggest
that trump willfully made statements
that in context encouraged and
foreseeably resulted in lawless action
at the capitol
such as quote if you don't fight like
hell you're not gonna have a country
anymore thus incited by president trump
members of the crowd he had addressed in
an attempt to among other objectives
interfere with the joint sessions solemn
constitutional duty to certify the
results of the 2020 election
unlawfully breached and vandalized the
capital et cetera et cetera et cetera
trump's lawyers say
it is admitted that persons unlawfully
breached and vandalized the capital that
people were injured and killed that law
enforcement is currently investigating
and prosecuting
those who were responsible seditious
acts is a term of art with a legal
meaning and the use of that phrase in
the article of impeachment is thus
denied in the context in which it was
used
it is denied that trump incited the
crowd to engage in destructive behavior
it is denied that the phrase if you
don't fight like hell you're not going
to have a country anymore
had anything to do with the action at
the capitol as it was clearly about the
need to fight for election security in
general as evidenced by the recording of
the speech
it is denied that trump intended to
interfere with the counting of electoral
votes
as is customary members of congress
challenged electoral vote submissions by
state under a process written into the
congressional rules allowing for the
respective houses of congress to debate
whether a state's submitted electoral
votes should be counted
in 2017 democrats repeatedly challenged
the electoral votes submitted from
states where trump prevailed in 2021
republican members of congress
challenged the electoral votes submitted
from states where biden prevailed the
purpose of the joint sessions in 2017
and
in 2021 was for members of congress to
fulfill their duty to be certain
the electoral college votes were
properly submitted its duty was to first
determine whether certification
of the presidential election vote was
warranted and permissible under its
rules
okay so the the actual strong case they
have here and i'm kind of surprised
that they didn't actually cite it is
that trump actively said in that speech
he wanted people to peacefully protest
and by the way
holding some sort of protest on the day
that an action is to be taken is not
unusual at all right that sort of stuff
happens all the time there are protests
on the day of trump's inauguration in
2017. there are protests at the supreme
court nearly every term
as the court decisions are being read
inside right trump has a pretty
strong defense on the idea that just
because he held a rally the day of the
electoral vote certification this means
that he was actively directing people to
storm the capitol building
especially when he did in fact say that
he wanted people to peacefully protest
and i think frankly that that's actually
what he wanted he just he didn't
what he wanted was not people to storm
the capital what he wanted was the
images
of thousands of people protesting the
results of the election
okay then we'll get to the rest of the
the trump defense
team brief in just one second and then
we'll get to
the the way that democrats are playing
this thing because it really is not
about punishing trump
for anything at this point what they
actually just want is the continuation
of this entire line of narrative for as
long as possible so of course they can
lump everybody they don't like in with
it
and so they can claim that all
republicans were in favor of what
happened on january 6th this has been
the move
since january 6th i called it that day
nothing has changed
okay we're gonna get some more of this
in just one second first valentine's day
is coming up and let me tell you about a
fantastic fantastic gift you can get
for girlfriend your wife on valentine's
day i of course
am talking about jewelry it's the go-to
right dudes it is the go-to
and i have the best place for you to get
jewelry right now there's nothing more
classic and timeless than fine pearl
jewelry
it doesn't need to break your budget at
the pearl source you get the highest
quality pearl jewelry at up to 70
off retail prices why well the pearl
source cuts out the middle man
they eliminate traditional five times
markups by jewelry stores they sell
directly to you
the consumer if you can't find that
perfect item at your local jewelry store
the pearl source is for you can shop
safely and securely from the comfort of
your home
at the pearl source you'll find the
largest selection of pearls available
anywhere
each jewelry piece is custom made for
you and if you need it quickly for
valentine's day
no problem at all pearlsource offers
fast and free two-day shipping on every
order zero contact
delivery and if she doesn't like it
you're worried she doesn't want
it she doesn't like your taste well the
pearl source comes with a no hassle 60
day money back guarantee it is
absolutely
risk-free don't overpay for the jewelry
that you are buying for your loved one
on valentine's day first of all i can
just tell you this company is reliable
because i know the people who own it
they're wonderful wonderful family
people
their company is terrific i have gotten
jewelry from the pearl source
for my wife she loves it she wears it
all the time for a limited time
listeners to this show can take 20 off
your entire order for valentine's day
go to thepearlsource.com enter promo
code ben and check out for 20
off your entire order if you want fine
jewel find pearl jewelry at the best
prices online
go straight to the source the pearl
source once again that's the
pearlsource.com enterprise
at checkout for 20 off your entire order
okay so
continuing with the trump legal team's
response to the impeachment impeachment
charges
so the impeachment charges suggest that
president trump's conduct on january 6
followed his prior efforts to subvert
the certification of the results of the
2020 presidential election these prior
efforts included a phone call on january
2nd
2021 during which trump urged the
secretary of state of georgia brad
raffensberger to quote unquote find
enough votes to overturn the georgia
presidential election results and
threatened
secretary raffensberger if he failed to
do so here is what
the trump team responds they say it is
admitted trump spoke on the telephone
with secretary raffensburg and multiple
other parties including several
attorneys for both parties
on january 2nd secretary raffensberger
or someone at his direction
surreptitiously recorded the call
and subsequently made it public the
recording accurately reflects the
content of the conversation
it is denied that president trump made
any effort to subvert the certification
of the results of the 2020 presidential
election
it is denied that the word find was
inappropriate in context as trump was
expressing his opinion that if the
evidence was carefully examined one
would quote find
that you have many that aren't signed
and you have many that are forgeries it
is denied that trump threatened
secretary raffensberger it is denied
that trump acted improperly
in that telephone call in any way that
sentence was inserted by president trump
i think pretty clearly on a personal
level okay so i said at the time that
the call was inappropriate it was wrong
trump shouldn't have done it
also i was struggling to find what
exactly the threat was
right he was saying that it's gonna be
unpopular in georgia if
i don't win the election that happens to
be true he was also saying that he
thinks because he believes every rumor
that reaches his ears about voter fraud
or voter irregularity even if they have
been disproved 1 000 times
that those votes were actually out there
trump believing it
does have something to do with whether
he was lying or not he could be mistaken
he could be doing something wrong
but the idea that he was prying votes
that he who's encouraging raffensburger
to manufacture votes out of thin
air is uh is i think a little bit of a
stretch although that that again is the
strongest part of the impeachment charge
against trump
for sure okay finally the impeachment
charge says trump gravely endangered the
security of the united states and its
institutions of government et cetera et
cetera
trump's lawyers respond it is denied he
threatened the integrity of the
democratic system interfered with the
peaceful transition of power and imperil
the co-equal branch of government
it is denied he betrayed his trust as
president to manifest injury of the
people
of the united states rather he performed
admirably in his role as president right
this is the part where trump
is sitting over his lawyer's shoulder
and being like you know what
no no i was the best president whoever
okay in any case
the fact is that that trump's legal
defense team
has a fairly strong legal response to
the impeachment charges because again
those are over broad they establish
principles that are not neutral and
cannot be neutrally applied
right that's the case that i've been
making for a while plus he keeps going
back to this case that you really can't
impeach me because i'm not in office
anymore now here's the reality the
proper response to trump's activity
particularly now that he's out of office
would be accenture from congress so
wouldn't you get bipartisan support for
that censure
the answer is yes okay our politics is
very often about deliberately avoiding
the consensus position
in favor of the non-consensus position
so you can cast your opponents as
terrible people
that is what our politics generally is
about it is not about finding common
ground
it is about refusing to find the common
ground so you
can pretend that the other guy is
actually crazy or radical or a problem
so censure would be a well-supported
thing on both sides of the aisle i think
it would be very difficult
for republicans not to vote to censure
trump i think it'd be very difficult for
them not to do that
okay but chuck schumer was asked about
this the senate majority leader and he
said nope
we're not even going to consider censure
right not we should bring up century and
we should bring up impeachment people
can vote for either now he doesn't want
republicans to have the off-ramp of
censure
he wants to make it a binary choice
between the impeachment charges passed
in the house
and nothing and then he can claim that
if you don't vote for impeachment that
is not because you have problems with
the impeachment charges it's because you
were totally fine with all of trump's
behavior and
you're fine with what happened on
january 6th so here's schumer saying no
no we're not going to do censure censor
should not even be introduced
the question is though there was a lot
of conversation last week from senator
kaine and others
seeing the writing on the wall as to the
votes that maybe if he's not convicted
do a censure for the president are you
open to that as an author
i think the president should be tried i
hope he will vote to be convicted
anything past that um is something we
can discuss
but he deserves conviction
nothing less nothing less that's what he
deserves okay well
in reality after the impeachment happens
if if democrats then introduce censure
then it's going to be difficult for them
to make that case because they tried
impeachment it failed now it just looks
like you're going back to the well
a second time okay in one second we're
going to get to the continued push
to suggest that everybody who disagrees
with chuck schumer and nancy pelosi
and joe biden on any measure is actually
in league with the people of january
6 the criminals on january 6. we'll get
to that in one second first let us talk
about your sleep quality so
my baby woke me up at 5 30 this morning
i'm exhausted but
i am less exhausted than it would be if
i didn't have my helix sleep mattress
because that is the way that i get the
sleep that i get if i didn't have
healing sleep i'd be up like all might
helix sleep mattress i'm not an easy
sleeper helix sleep
made a mattress just for me it's
personalized just for me because
everybody is unique and helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they've soft
medium firm mattresses
mattresses that are great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot they've got a
helix plus mattress for plus size folks
it's been
awesome getting unboxing videos from so
many folks who listened to the show
who've gotten that helix sleep mattress
it is indeed the best mattress on the
market you need to take my word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020
by both gq and wired magazine head on
over to helixsleep.com take their
two-minute sleep quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress that'll
give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you can try it out
for a hundred nights with cruise you
really have nothing to lose they'll pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
you will
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com once
again
that is helixsleep.com go check them out
right now helixsleep.com
okay so the the democratic party
has decided that they are going to
eschew all possibility
of unity or agreement on nearly
any issue and they're going to do so by
ignoring their overall positions on a
wide variety of things in the past
right so they are very much against
political violence except when members
of their side are doing it they're very
much against inflammatory language
except when alexander ocasio-cortez
is accusing ted cruz of attempting to
murder her and comparing him
to her sexual assaulter her alleged
sexual assaulter
they're all in favor of good things
except when the good things apply to the
other side then they are in favor
of the bad things so yesterday the the
members of the media were very very
upset
because the brian sicknick memorial
happened at the capitol
and um and first of all i think it's
great that they
had brian sicknick lion state at the
capitol building the guy the guy's a
hero he's an officer who died in the
line of duty protecting
members of congress elected members of
congress from a violent mob
i think it's perfectly appropriate that
he should lie in state at the capitol
building
and joe biden went and he visited fox
news didn't cover this very much they
covered it a little bit
cnn msnbc had it on complete streaming
coverage
now let me just point out it's not
because cnn and msnbc
are so deeply concerned with the honor
of police officers generally that they
did this
okay cnn and msnbc have a political acts
to grind now i think that all three
networks should have covered this at
length
i do i think that they should have all
streamed the live coverage because i
think that officers who die in the line
of duty protecting members of congress
from a violent mob
deserve that sort of tribute from
everyone from everyone
i also think that members of cnn msnbc
if officer stiknick
had been had had been killed in the line
of duty
during a blm riot i do not think that if
donald trump had said that person should
lie in state they would have covered it
nearly the same way right then it would
have been well you know the police are
systemically racist and it's kind of a
tragedy that that happened but
let's be frank about this the police
they they have a real they have a real
bad relationship with so many members of
the public
i'm i'm having a tough time swallowing
the line from members of the media that
they are deeply concerned with the honor
of police officers after they have spent
years
ripping on police officers i just have a
real problem with that basic idea
like i think that folks like me who have
been i've consistently defended the cops
in the face of malign attacks against
them by members of the media
in the face of lies told about them by
politicians
i have defended police officers the
police are the people who stand between
us
and chaos and that's why i'm very happy
that they actually did this for brian
signing i think it's a good thing
but when the members of the media
suddenly start suggesting that
republicans are are
not in favor of the police because they
want for impeachment or when they
suddenly when it suddenly strikes them
that the police are good
right but but only under certain
circumstances i find it just a little
bit hypocritical
just a little hypocritical in any case
here was the uh here was a little bit of
the footage from the cycnic memorial
he said it's joe biden and uh he's
approaching the
brian sicknick memorial there is a
folded flag obviously
for the officer i mean it's a tragedy
obviously it's a this is a this is a man
who died in the line of duty
stopping an act of evil and he deserves
every plaudit that he receives does
officer
brian signing uh i just wish that the
the
i i wish to god that the democrats were
consistent in their respect
for police they obviously obviously
obviously are not everybody
should be okay meanwhile members of the
press continue
along the lines of if you disagree with
me then
you are responsible for the riot uh
briana keeler from cnn
who used to be a lot better as an anchor
and she has morphed into a sort of don
lemon type
very wild-eyed leftist at this point on
cnn she
is now suggesting that senator cruz
incited the riot
as donald trump's second impeachment
trial nears there is one senator who led
the charge to challenge the electoral
college count
and enthusiastically threw his weight
behind multiple
efforts to undermine the democratic
presidential election and is now trying
to cleanse himself of the stain of those
actions
cruz didn't seem to mind the quote
reckless and irresponsible rhetoric from
the president
in fact cruz joined in speaking to
voters in georgia in early january just
days before the senate runoffs there
okay so again the idea is that anybody
who backed
trump's suggestion that the election
results ought to be challenged they are
responsible for the rise and i think
that that was wrong what cruz did
i think that it was wrong what holly did
i don't think that any of that is
responsible for the riots i believe that
adults have agency there are plenty of
adults who came and rallied with trump
and who left
in the middle of the riots or before the
riots even occurred
nonetheless again the goal of the press
here i keep saying it over and over and
over because people need to see through
the veil the press are not honest
brokers they are not even attempting to
be honest brokers here we all know this
it is perfectly obvious to everyone who
has brain what exactly the press are
doing these are not folks who are
standing up for the institutions of our
democracy
these are folks who are perfectly fine
with undermining institutions of our
democracy on a fairly regular basis
depending on who is doing the
undermining these are folks who cheered
on violence throughout the summer
and no that is not an apple store or
just comparison is that a comparison
that is an apples to apples comparison
it's not what about ism because some of
us condemned violence all the way
through
and yet here you have michael beschloss
the historian suggesting that america
should treat january 6th
historically like 9 11. we should
memorialize the date of the capital
insurrection just like 9 11.
he says it's like the day we almost lost
our democracy no actually it was not
i'm sorry it didn't even come close to
us losing our democracy it came close to
being an awful evil tragic incident like
the congressional baseball shooting
it was a breach of our values for sure
it was ugly
i said i think it was the ugliest public
spectacle since 9 11 in the united
states
but should we memorialize it the same
way that we memorialized the death
of 3 000 americans because a bunch of
nuts
and violent mob and a violent mob was
stopped by the cops before
they could do serious damage and let's
not let's be frank about this there was
no threat to the overall democracy of
the united states you want to see an
overall threat to democracy take a look
at myanmar but right now a military coup
is in place okay that is not the same
thing as a bunch of
mob idiots storming a capitol building
okay so never mind the uh never mind the
actual history never mind the actual
comparisons here's michael bischloss the
historian
suggesting that we should treat january
6 like 9 11 as the day we almost lost
our democracy again
this is such hyperbolic nonsense
conceivably this could have taken away
our democracy
and this is one reason why i think we
have to observe
the 6th of january every single year as
a time that we had a very close call
to remind us that we have to be
eternally vigilant because democracy
is fragile you know rachel we we
observed 9 11.
we remember the fact that there were
attacks that landed
one that almost landed which was an
effort to fly an airplane
into the capital kill a lot of members
of congress
that almost happened here is a terrorist
attack that did happen
okay uh of wait is he just calling 911 a
terrorist attack that didn't happen
and that like the fact that they didn't
hit the capitol building on 9 11
is one of the things we remember least
about 9 11. the thing we remember most
about 9 11 is the images of planes
flying into the world trade center and
taking down both towers plus another
plane flying into the pentagon and
another plane
being crashed into a field in
pennsylvania that's that's those are the
things that i remember about 911
the the desire to turn january 6th into
a referendum
on the fragility of our democracy
generally is
i think quite silly and again it really
is more tied
to what people want to happen next it's
not about what happened on january 6
that's what people want
to happen next and the media want this
more than anything the media more than
anything
want a a crackdown on people they
dislike
they want to justify any attack of any
kind on people
they dislike the media are just over the
moon about alexander ocasio-cortez's
comparison between
her alleged sexual assaulter and ted
cruz and josh halley which is
i'm sorry a morally absurd comparison
people who disagree with you politically
even if they do stuff that is cynical
and that you don't like
are not like people who tried to rape
you or who did rape you that is not the
same thing that is not the same thing in
any way
and yet we're told by monica hess the
columnist at the washington post
alexander ocasio-cortez says she was
told that trauma victims
should tell their stories as part of
their healing and that is what she did
monday night in the most compelling
heartbreaking and infuriating 60 minutes
available on any screen
at any time this week she talked about
her how she found herself questioning
the motives of a law enforcement officer
who had given her hazy instructions on
how to reach an evacuation point by the
way
i will note that people are ignoring the
fact that uh during that live stream
alexander ocasio-cortez suggested that a
police officer who came to help her
might have in fact she was suspicious
that he was in fact a white supremacist
in disguise because he was white and the
respect for police officer is going
right out the window
on that one according to monica hess aoc
compared it to a sexual harasser telling
his victim the quickest path to normalcy
would be her forgiving him
or the parents telling the child they
once abused that the mistreatment had
happened in the past
okaza cortez's whole live stream was
brave but this was the bravest part when
she cried fell on a warped view of
reconciliation in which those who stoked
the fires of anger and false belief that
fueled the attack demand that the
victims simply forgive
and forget well that's not all she did
right she compared them to rapists and
sexual assaulters but
she's gonna receive the plaudits of the
media in the lifestyle section by the
way
of the washington post meanwhile what is
this going to lead to
well what this is really going to lead
to is the media calling for more
crackdowns on people
with whom they disagree i mean we can
all see which way this is going what
they would like is a media
monopoly they also need a new narrative
i mean this is this is the other point
here
you are in order to push forward the
narrative the january 6th was not
an outlier that the people who stormed
the capital are actually a mainstream
part of the republican party
the media have started to push forward
forward in in very strong fashion
marjorie taylor greene who again was a
no-name back bencher that no one cared
about until five minutes ago and the
media started pushing her extremely hard
they did some oppo they found a bunch of
bad stuff that she had said in the past
and now it's every republican is respon
the republican party is marjorie taylor
green we ready to send those headlines
yesterday
headline after headline the republican
party is marjorie taylor green that's
what they are
the new headline front page of the new
york times under pressure to rebuke
their own gop leaders face a critical
test
the fates of representative marjorie
taylor green and liz chaney have become
a proxy battle for the soul of the party
prompting a clash
among top republicans trump loyalists
want to strip representative liz cheney
of wyoming the number three republican
of her leadership post his payback for
her vote to impeach
trump critics want to strip
representative marjory taylor green of
georgia of her committee assignments for
endorsing false claims bigoted language
and violent behavior
including calling for the execution of
top democrats uh i'm i'm just wondering
there are a lot of people who are not
who really probably could not be
categorized as trump critics who are in
favor of stripping marjorie taylor
greene
of her committee assignments just going
to point that out but again the goal
here is that the media have to find
a new way to push the narrative that
they were able to push so successfully
during the trump administration
which was here is a villain this villain
represents all of republican dumb
and so they have settled on marjorie
taylor green by the way they need that
narrative in terms of the ratings you're
seeing a lot of headlines today
about how cnn is was the number one
cable network in january
that's not really a surprise they have a
lot of reporters on the ground and the
news cycle
was uh not a pleasant one for
conservatives and republicans right
trump leaves office the january sixth
riots the
the yeah trump's behavior like the
impeachment like
these were not news cycles that
generally are going to make republicans
happy
as a general rule right and particularly
not when the media have declared that
you're in league with all of the bad
things
that happened and so a lot of
republicans tuned out after the election
and tuned out after january 6th
and a lot of democrats were watching tv
with eagerness
and anticipation there i mean this was
like
it was the greatest time ever to be a
democrat basically between
january 15th and january 20th
essentially between the impeachment and
when biden took office this was like the
best time to be a democratic tv watcher
because you were watching
as what you saw as the collapse of the
republican party was unfolding
the repudiation of everything trump was
happening it was just it was great right
so the
the ratings spiked for cnn and msnbc
and they declined for fox news so what
you're seeing right now is all these
headlines saying well look at fox fox is
really in trouble cnn and msnbc they're
really on the rise look at
yeah there's only one problem the minute
that joe biden took office
cnn's ratings tanked the minute it
happened
it literally three days after that
happened cnn's ratings plummeted they
went directly in the toilet
foxes which had declined after the
election stayed pretty much steady
so here is the the headline you're
seeing is cnn wins month of january
here's the real headline okay the real
headline that matters
because this is going to drive what the
media coverage says for the next several
years
tim pierce of daily wire cnn's ratings
tanked 44
the week after trump left the white
house 44
in the first week of the biden
administration cnn saw the audiences
that had been flooding into prime time
recently
dropped precipitously on january 25th to
29th compared with the highs of previous
weeks
meanwhile rival fox news channel spot's
own ratings only dip slightly
after weeks of registering its own sharp
declines msnbc has also seen
significant declines nowhere if steep is
what has hit cnn that makes sense
because the most
rabid democrat partisans are still
tuning over to msnbc particularly at
nine o'clock hour
but cnn which draws sort of the casual
democrat those people are like yeah you
know biden's president now i don't care
i'm ready to move on with my life
cnn ended the final week of january with
ratings dropping roughly 44
for total audience versus the prior week
across all three hours
of prime time so that is that that's
what's driving some of this media
coverage to pretend that the media
coverage is completely disconnected from
the ratings
is obviously untrue and so the new plan
for the
for the media is sort of the same as the
old plan they got to find a villain
they have to polarize the country around
that villain they have to suggest that
everybody they don't like is in league
with that villain and then they have to
suggest that the solution to that is the
all-powerful all-good
sword-wielding king on high joe biden
and that is the way they are doing this
that's the way this is going to be so
we're going to get nothing but wall to
wall non-stop coverage of marjory taylor
green who yes should be stripped of her
committee assignments that is okay she
shouldn't be
in a position of power on committees the
republican party does not have to give
her committee assignments
but also mitch mcconnell calls her a
cancer within the party so the media's
narrative just to point this out
just to point out the hypocrisy and
ridiculousness here among democrats and
the media
their narrative is marjorie taylor green
who is probably going to be stripped of
her committee assignments when all this
is said and done
is the face of the republican party
however it is very very good
that the faces of the democratic party
are people like rashida talib
and ilhan omar and let me just point out
right now rashida taliban open
anti-semite serves on the house
committee on financial services
the house committee on oversight and
reform and she's joined a bunch of
powerful caucuses inside the democratic
party ilhan omar who's an open
anti-semite
she serves on the house budget committee
and the house
foreign affairs committee how in the
hell is she on the house foreign affairs
committee
she's a blatant anti-semite who who once
wrote in defense of a person trying to
join isis
she wrote a judge asking that person get
a lower sentence because systemic
american racism had created the
conditions by which this person felt
dispossessed
that person is sitting on the house
foreign affairs committee when are the
democrats going to strip her of her
assignments the answer of course is
never
but this is the media agenda and the
media agenda uber alice it matters more
than anything anything anything else
i have a couple other examples of this
in just one second
some of them are fairly egregious and
some are kind of just hilarious we'll
get to that in a moment first
let us talk about the facts you don't
want to be going to the auto parts store
right now you just don't
i mean like when would you ever want to
you're going to overpay you're going to
get to the front of the line
they're finally going to find you the
part that you need and then they're
going to order it online and you're just
going to have to come back later so why
not just go to the interwebs find the
part that you need get it
delivered straight to you and not pay
that giant markup that you're going to
get at an auto parts store this is where
rockauto.com
comes in they're always going to offer
you the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear like airlines do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts rockauto.com it's a
family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
head on over to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same
for professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts the rockauto.com
catalog is unique
it's remarkably easy to navigate quickly
see all the parts available for your
vehicle
choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer they've got amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car is ever going to need
head on over to rockauto.com go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro
and then how did you hear about xbox so
they know that we sent
you all right we're gonna get some more
content in just one second first
daily wire we've entered the cultural
fight okay right now the culture wars
are pretty much everything
conservatives have spent decades
complaining that there is no
conservative culture and that
conservatives are thrown out of the
culture
so we here are getting active and we are
creating our own earlier this month
we released our first film run hide
fight exclusively for daily wire members
you can catch it over at dailywire.com
on our mobile app on our streaming apps
at apple tv and roku
if you're not a daily wire member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25
off that is rhf for 25 percent off
there's a reason audiences
are loving it if you head on over to
rotten tomatoes right now
and you check out run hide fight on
rotten tomatoes what you will see is one
of these enormous critical gaps right 25
positive from the critics 93 positive
from
our audience that's the kind of stuff
that we intend on making stuff the
critics will hate but you will love you
can catch it over at dailywire.com
on our mobile app or on our streaming
apps at apple tv and roku if you're not
a daily ware member yet use promo code
rhf to get 25
off that is rhf run hide fight for 25
percent off you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio join the nation
[Music]
now one of the beautiful things if
you're a member of the media about this
narrative that you've been pushing
one of the most wonderful things about
the opportunity that has presented
itself in the wake
of the trump presidency is that you can
call for a top-down control on
information and that's exactly what
folks over at the new york times are
doing so kevin ruse who spends his
entire life basically just tracking
facebook traffic
and then if conservatives get too much
of it he tweets out every single day
that conservative facebook pages are
getting traffic
now this ignores a bunch of data like
for example the fact
that half of the top publishers on the
facebook platform are of the left
many more than that actually if you look
at the top facebook publishers of the
top 25
16 are of the left well a vast majority
are from the left but of course the idea
is the conservatives should not be able
to get any facebook traffic
and then you have the media pushing out
studies that suggest you know it's all
mythical
when conservatives worry about a
crackdown on tech freedom
right when when conservatives worry
about being deplatformed that's all a
myth it's all a lie they put out a study
that was commissioned by a member of i
believe the biden transition team or
somebody who's involved
with biden's campaign it was
commissioned by a business person who
supported biden
and quoted media matters in the study
and then they were like oh look at this
great study okay if you're quoting media
matters by definition it's a crappy
study
okay done here it is that simple okay
but it doesn't just go that far it's not
just trying to pressure the social tech
guys it is also
how we constitute government so kevin
ruse so as i say the new york times
is along with kara swisher the leader of
the activist
forced big tech to stop the means of
dissemination for conservatives movement
ruth says last month millions of
americans watched as president biden
took the oath of office
and in a high-minded inaugural address
called for a new era of american unity
but plenty of other americans weren't
paying attention mr biden speech they
were too busy watching youtube videos
that alleged the inauguration was a
pre-recorded hoax that had been filmed
on a hollywood sound stage
or they were melting down and q and on
group chats trying to figure out why
former president trump wasn't
interrupting biden's speech
to declare martial law and announce the
mass arrest of satanic pedophiles or
maybe
their tvs were tuned to oan where an
anchor was floating the baseless theory
that biden wasn't actually elected by
the people hey you'll notice something
at the very top of this column from
kevyn ross he doesn't give you any
numbers
right i thought he's captain data over
here how many people were watching the
inauguration versus how many people
were participating in in those
particular activities i would i would
suggest it was probably
somewhat disproportionate isn't wildly
disproportionate which is a good thing
but he's not going to tell you that
right the idea is that these people are
an existential threat to democracy and
we must stop them
okay so again i i think that their ideas
are bad
i think their ideas are in some cases
evil i think they're being fed a pack of
lies
but i do not think they are an
existential threat to the democracy of
the united states sufficient
to call for the things that kevin roost
then calls for okay hoaxes
lies and collective delusions aren't new
says kevin roose but the extent to which
millions of americans have embraced them
maybe thirty percent of republicans have
a favorable favorable view
of q anon according to a recent ugov
poll according to other polls more than
70 percent of republicans believe
trump legitimately won the election 40
of americans including plenty of
democrats believe the baseless theory
that coveted 19 was manufactured in a
chinese lab
okay a few things about this one in the
aftermath of the 2016 election a
majority of democrats believe trump
wasn't
rightly elected okay as far as the the q
anon conspiracy theorizing
in the aftermath of 9 11 there were a
bunch of if you'd taken a poll of
democrats
on conspiracy theories about 9 11 a
significant percentage of democrats
believed
some conspiracy theories about 9
probably a majority of democrats believe
the
bush lied people died warfare oil and
rock conspiracy theorizing
and as far as the baseless theory
coveted 19 was manufactured in a chinese
lab
okay it is it is i'm wondering
what is incredibly baseless about that i
mean if you mean that it was like
weaponized by the military and then
unleashed on an unsuspecting population
that's baseless but there's fairly solid
evidence that the vaccine
that the covid 19 virus itself was
manipulated in a chinese lab and then
was accidentally released i mean that
the atlantic reported on that like this
month in any case kevin roose who is not
up on the best information he says the
muddled
chaotic information ecosystem that
produces these misguided beliefs
doesn't just jeopardize some lofty ideal
of national unity it actively
exacerbates our biggest national
problems
and creates more work in trying to solve
them and it raises an important question
for the biden administration
how to unite unite a country in which
millions of people have chosen to create
their own version of reality okay so
this is where it comes down to to what
he wants right now is the opportunity
for the new york times and kevin ruse
and karis wisher
to redefine reality for you along the
lines of their interpretation of reality
now there are certain things that are
said they're just blatantly untrue
ain't no jewish space laser okay as a
charter member of the jews i can tell
you ain't no jewish space laser that's
absolutely false however there are also
a bunch of claims that i think are false
that are open to contention such as
america is systemically racist and its
police are systemically racist and
therefore the disproportionate number of
black men going to prison is a
reflection of american racism and racist
police forces i don't think there's data
to back that up democrats push it every
single day
there's certainly no data to back the
idea that the police are randomly
killing black men in the street that is
not true that is not true on its face
democrats continue to push that would
kevin roose
silence those views no he would actually
propagate those views presumably
but says kevin roose it's time to crack
down on free speech this is the
direction we are moving quote
i've spent the past several years
reporting on our national reality crisis
and i worry that unless the biden
administration treats conspiracy
theories and disinformation as the
urgent threats they are
our parallel universes will only drift
further apart and the potential for
violent
unrest and civic dysfunction will only
grow so i called tantra
experts yay let's talk to some experts
on free speech
see i think that we're all experts on
free speech because um it turns out it's
just a value
and free speech as a value means that
you're gonna have to rebut bad ideas
and that people have a right to speak
those bad ideas but says kevin roose
no he's going to call some experts so
let's talk about what kevin roose says
the experts have to say
he says assess the damage and avoid the
quote unquote terrorist trap the experts
agreed that before the biden
administration can tackle disinformation
and extremism
it needs to understand the scope of the
problem william braniff a
counter-terrorism expert and professor
at the university of maryland says quote
it's really important that we have a
holistic understanding of what the
spectrum of violent extremism looks in
the united states and then allocate
resources accordingly
joan donovan the research director of
harvard university's shorenstein center
on media politics and public policy
suggested that the biden administration
could set up a truth commission
that's not orwellian in any sense a
government-run truth commission
oh goody-goody gumdrops the government
can determine for you what the truth is
via a truth commission
okay truth is not is not self-evident to
people
and so we must have a commission that
determines truth
um this is going to go well she says
it'll be similar to the 911
commission to investigate the planning
and execution of the capital siege on
january 6th
okay now i don't know why you would call
that a truth commission why would you
not just
call that the january 6th commission the
reason you're calling
it the truth commission is of course
because you don't want it to be about
the january 6th riot at all
you want to be about a broader
perception of reality how broad well
broad enough that it will encompass all
the
bad views of your political opponents dr
donovan says
dr donovan professor donovan said quote
there must be accountability for these
actions my fear is that we'll get
distracted as a society and focus too
much on giving voice to the fringe
groups that came out
in droves for trump these experts were
heartened
to see that the biden administration had
already announced a comprehensive threat
assessment of domestic extremism but
they cautioned that while
that categorizing these extremists as
domestic terrorists could backfire
because counter-terrorism efforts had
historically been used to justify
expanding state powers
in ways that end up harming religious
and ethnic minorities
and that today's domestic extremism
crisis doesn't map neatly onto older
more conventional types of terror
threats
okay here's where it gets really fun
several experts kevin roos spoke to
recommended the biden administration put
together a cross-agency task force
to tackle disinformation and domestic
extremism which would be led by
something like a
reality czar oh good so we've got truth
commissions and realities ours things
are going real hot over the new york
times
the the free speech advocates over at
the new york times are calling for truth
commissions and realities ours
hmm can't see this being misused in any
way
kevin roos even is like now that it
comes out of my mouth it sounds weird he
says
it sounds a little dystopian i'll grant
but let's hear them out
or we could not and just an idea i'm
just going to throw this out there the
government shouldn't have a reality czar
because that's ridiculous and a
violation of the first amendment
and stupid on its face but no let's hear
them out
right now say experts the federal
government's response to disinformation
and domestic extremism
is haphazard and spread across multiple
agencies there's a lot of unnecessary
overlap
rene dressta a disinformation researcher
at stanford's internet observatory
gave the example of two seemingly
unrelated problems misinformation about
covet 19
and misinformation about election fraud
often she said
the same people in groups are
responsible for spreading both types so
instead of two parallel processes
one at the centers for disease control
and prevention aimed at tamping down
coveted related conspiracy theories
and another at the federal election
commission trying to correct voting
misinformation
a centralized task force could
coordinate a single strategic response
this task force could meet regularly
with tech platforms and push for
structural changes that could help these
companies
tackle their own extremism and
misinformation problems
for example it could formulate safe
harbor exemptions that would allow
platforms to share data about q anon and
other conspiracy theories
with researchers and government agencies
without running afoul of privacy laws
oh that's a great idea so the government
is going to create back doors
for the tech agencies to pass on
information they normally wouldn't be
allowed to pass on
if you believe kooky things about the
world
good not this won't be misused in any
way no way no way you're gonna ever have
a government that sets up
back doors that say does this person
believe in smaller government and
individual freedom
or by the way if you're on the left does
this person believe the police should be
disfunded what
defunded maybe we should you know have a
back door and then the government can
have all their personal information and
keep tabs on them
can't see how this is going to go wrong
in any way like a mass surveillance
state pushed by the government
on the basis of their own determination
of reality and truth
a member of the new york times is saying
this in the technology section
yeah you can see what the agenda here is
also they want to audit the algorithms
and they don't just want to stop there
this is what
kara swisher and kevin roose and juggler
gamble and all the rest of the uh the
activist slash journalists have been
saying for a while
basically they want to take control of
the algorithms and use the algorithms on
the tech platforms
in order to downgrade any content they
don't like so kevin ruth says
several experts recommended the biden
administration push for much more
transparency into the inner workings of
the black box
black box algorithms twitter facebook
youtube and other major platforms used
to rank feeds
recommend content and usher users into
private groups many of which have been
responsible for amplifying conspiracy
theories
and extremist views so great they should
they should just give their algorithms
over to the government and the
government can control the algorithms
the fact that these people are so
confident in their control of the
institutions that it never occurs to
them that maybe when you establish this
sort of government power can be used
against you
it's just demonstration of again their
own perception
of their ascendancy and the fact they're
never going to give out power
so they're just going to cement
themselves into power using this sort of
stuff and the media are complicit in
this
the media democrat complex is so
powerful at this point
it's truly amazing it's truly amazing
speaking of which it's it's amazing to
watch
as the democrats continue to blame
republicans for the school closures
lori lightfoot who again cut a video in
the immediate aftermath of joe biden's
election saying that
now the science had arrived back on the
scene she's still blaming trump for her
own schools being closed in her own city
because she's caving to the teachers
unions who spend money on her election
here she is blaming trump a person who's
been out of office for a while and was
pushing for school reopenings
for the schools being closed in chicago
this is a
a very difficult situation and we're in
it
still because of the incompetence of the
previous administration
so i think it's important for both sides
to come to the table in good faith
recognize uh that we're both trying to
work through
a very challenging situation but we must
get
a deal done okay so uh
pretty amazing it's still trump
everything's it's just gonna remain
trump's fault forever i think
is sort of the idea because when you
have trump in the in the rearview mirror
then you can just blame everything
on him and you can move forward with
your most world-breaking agenda paul
krugman who's wrong on nearly everything
he said yesterday you know what
republicans keep talking about this
stuff like the national debt the
national debt just doesn't matter now i
will admit that paul krugman at least
has been consistent on this
and he he always says the national debt
doesn't matter because he's wild when it
comes to monetary policy he's actually a
new dev he used to believe
that modern monetary theory which was
the idea you can just spend money
forever
and no one will ever call it in that
that was a he used to believe that was
idiotic
now he has shifted his opinion because
of course he is very much in favor of
just spending endless amounts of money
he says the national debt doesn't matter
just blow it out man
there's been a real sea change in
mainstream economic views that says the
debt is just not that big of a problem
now if you want to disagree with that
okay but the republican party has no
standing to do
that because they have been so obviously
they didn't care about debt when
a republican when bush was president
they suddenly cared about when obama was
president they stopped caring when
when uh when trump came in and now they
care about it again with biden so they
they just have no credibility if someone
wants to make a serious argument that
isn't so
obviously partisan fine but the
mainstream economic view now is that the
depth that's being incurred
is not a problem whereas failure to
provide enough economic relief during
this pandemic is a problem okay so a
couple of things one
he's actually not wrong the republicans
blew their credibility by not standing
up to big spending under trump that
actually is true but some of us were
pretty consistent on this
so we do get to complain about all this
meanwhile yamiche alcindor remember
yamiche alcindor is supposed to be a
reporter not an opinion journalist a
reporter
yamiche alcindor from from pbs she says
democrats just run right over the
republicans just
boom run them over this real bipartisan
language happening here
we cannot wait six months to have
negotiations we can't have the nine
month
back and forth where republicans give a
little and
democrats give a lot that that can't be
what happens because
if that is then there are going to be
millions of americans who aren't going
to get the vaccine
who aren't going to get the booster
shots that are needed so even if we have
enough vaccines for the summer
you're going to have to continuously
vaccinate americans i think that's
something that maybe is lost on people
and as a result
what you get is um a a real sense that
there needs to be
this this this push with democratic
power oh yeah you know it's
now it's urgent urgent right weird how
the urgency didn't exist before now it's
it's super urgent speaking of urgencies
joe biden is now pushing for more
executive orders we're just gonna govern
by executive orders
american america's former government has
turned into a vestigial legislature that
spends
extra extraordinary amounts of your
money the amounts of your money that do
not
exist i mean that we're going to have to
borrow from future generations
that's all they do and meanwhile we
elect effectively a dictator every four
years to reverse the other guys
executive orders and put and play some
new ones
here is here's joe biden doing some of
that yesterday
today i'm going to sign a few executive
orders um
to strengthen immigration system
building on
the executive actions i took on day one
to protect dreamers
and end the muslim ban and to better
manage our borders
and that's what these uh three different
uh
executive orders about i want to make it
clear there's a lot of talk
with good reason about the number of
executive orders that i have signed
i'm not making new law i'm eliminating
bad policy
oh so if you're eliminating bad policy
it's not making new laws i guess the the
the math here okay but um what if you're
making
new law what if that's what you're
actually doing so here's what's actually
in some of the executive orders that
he's signing
so he is overthrowing the trump
administration policy
negotiated that were that allowed people
to apply for
citizenship from outside the country
basically if you came to the border and
you applied for asylum you had to wait
in mexico
while we adjudicated your asylum case he
is trying to overthrow that which of
course is going to
lead to a vast rush up to the border
okay also
another thing that he is going to be
doing is he is going to be setting up a
review
of trump error policies on on legal
immigration
and will streamline the naturalization
process and instruct agencies to review
the public charge rule which limited
green cards to immigrants who are deemed
likely to be reliant on welfare oh goody
so we can have immigrants who are deemed
likely to be on welfare
coming to the country in massive numbers
great great stuff here
that's going to be all good uh also by
the way joe biden is unleashing the
regulators so when he says he's not
making law
apparently he's also going to be
unleashing the right way quick note on
the immigration thing quick note here
uh i gotta love this headline from cnn
you ready for this biden administration
prepares to open overflow facility for
migrant children
overflow facility for migrant children
wait wait do you mean kids in cages
is that just a euphemism there
gang over at cnn an apple is an apple
and not a banana
according to cnn the biden
administration is opening an overflow
facility for unaccompanied migrant
children
apprehended at the u.s mexico border the
federal agency tasked
with the federal agency tasked with the
children's care told cnn in a statement
the health and human services department
will reopen a facility in carrizo
springs that can accommodate about 700
kids
and can be expanded if necessary oh look
look at that
they're they're not being placed in care
that they're they're being put in
an overflow facility for children weird
have the language change from the media
that way it was kids in cages when it
was trump before that it was just a bad
thing that was happening under obama but
it was really about trump
now they're doing exactly what trump was
doing but i guess it's good now so
that's exciting also joe biden is going
to be unleashing the regulators
mick mulvaney and joe grogan have a
piece of the wall street journal all
about this
talking about how a presidential memo
was released on january 20th
titled modernizing regulatory review
they say regulatory law is arcane and
generally boring but its effects can be
monumental the new presidential memo
tells the office of management
and budget how to do the the
cost-benefit analysis that so much
policy is based on
so what does the presidential memo do
it's intended to quote ensure
that the review process promotes
policies that reflect new developments
in scientific and economic understanding
fully accounts for regulatory benefits
that are difficult or impossible to
quantify
and does not have harmful
anti-regulatory or deregulatory
effects so what does that mean it means
that you're supposed to throw out
traditional
measures of cost-benefit analysis and
you're supposed to take into account
feelings oh yay we're supposed to take
into account
things that they legitimately are
arguing you cannot measure
the recommendations should provide
concrete suggestions on how the
regulatory review process can promote
public health and safety
economic growth social welfare racial
justice
economic stewardship human dignity
equity and the interests of future
generations
so says mick mulvaney the applications
are almost limitless you want to
regulate our
agricultural drainage ditches as
navigable water subject to federal rules
and restrictions
don't worry about whether food costs
might rise or farmers might go bankrupt
you can offset those costs with the
societal quote-unquote benefit an
unmeasurable societal benefit of
promoting the interests of future
generations
it doesn't matter if it can't be
measured it serves the desired end
right if there's a there's a housing
policy it turns out it's going to really
hurt the economy and it's going to cost
a fortune
doesn't matter you're affording quote
unquote racial justice and equity
so all this does is it basically removes
all limits on the cost-benefit analysis
provided to omb turning it into a
policy-making body
rather than what it was supposed to be
originally which was some sort of
objective
standard by which we measure whether a
policy is going to cost money or whether
it's going to create prosperity
so when people say that joe biden is
moderate he's pushing for moderate
bipartisan policies no not for one
second is joe biden pushing forward
moderate bipartisan policies not for one
single second of one single day so far
as we can see
thus far i'm waiting for bipartisanship
i've praised joe biden on some of the
things that he's done so far when he
sent
aircraft carriers into the south china
sea to try and defend against chinese
predations
i said that was a good thing i hope that
there will be more good things from the
biden administration we're not seeing a
lot of them
right now already we're going to be
doing another hour of content
coming up in the meantime go check out
the michael moles show
he's discussing blm being nominated for
the nobel peace prize
and frankly it's not a shock yasser
arafat once won the nobel peace prize
you can hear more details about this
story over on michael's show it is
available everywhere right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wiedowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
the senate prepares for the
pseudo-impeachment trial of former
president trump aoc compares ted cruz
and josh hawley to rapists
and blm gets nominated for a nobel peace
prize check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]
you